boba fett is one of the most iconic
characters in the star wars universe he
might just be one man but he's been
played by over a dozen actors since a
character was first created think you
can name them all
before the release of the empire strikes
back or even the infamous holiday
special boba fett made its debut at an
annual fall parade in san anselmo
california on sunday september 24th
1978. san anselmo was home to 52 parkway
often known as george lucas's secret
lair which is why it was chosen as the
site of the beloved bounty hunter's
premiere assistant film editor dwayne
dunham wore the famous armor in the
parade simply because he was the right
size sure have him turn around and get a
shot of the
jetpack
you do it dwayne
according to dunham the parade took
place on an extremely hot day in san
auselmo which he recalled could have
been 100 degrees since no one knew who
his character was at the time few fans
approached him though dunham did in fact
sign autographs for this he even had to
ask a nearby producer gary kurtz if fett
had one tea in it or two
the first on-screen appearance of boba
fett came two months after the san
auselmo parade during the now notorious
star wars holiday special the bounty
hunter shows up in an animated sequence
in which he is voiced by don franks i
take it you have no love of the empire
after the millennium falcon crashes on a
water planet luke and the droids try to
rescue their friends as soon as they
land however they're threatened by a
large beast that phet fights off thus
gaining the hero's trust in truth he's
been sent by the empire to infiltrate
the rebels in the hopes of finding the
location of their base franks was a
canadian actor who worked regularly up
until his passing in 2016 at the age of
84. his most visible roles include
walter on the canadian tv series le
femme nikita and chief jake newby in the
1981 slasher classic my bloody valentine
most fans didn't get to meet boba fett
until he went on the hunt for han solo
and the empire strikes back for most of
boba fett's scenes in that movie and
return of the jedi the man in the suit
is jeremy bullock the english actor who
had appeared in multiple british tv
series and films before becoming part of
star wars but his silent role as boba
fett remains by far his most well
remembered speaking to io9 in 2011
bollocks said he never expected boba
fett's character to become so popular
when asked what he thought boba got up
to after plunging into the sarlacc pit
bullock suggested that boba might have
tracked down and killed mace windu who
killed boba's father in attack of the
clones before appearing to die one movie
later bullock continued to act on enough
in the decades after empire and even
made a cameo appearance in revenge of
the sith in december 2020 he died at the
age of 75 from complications of
parkinson's disease
jeremy bollock's face only appears once
strong the empire strikes back and it
isn't while he's playing boba when luke
skywalker infiltrates bespin's cloud
city leia spots him and warns that he's
falling into a trap at the same time an
imperial officer is trying to pull her
away that officer is lieutenant shekel
played by bullock the production
shooting schedules conflicted at the
time however and in order to shoot that
scene bullock couldn't play boba fett in
another one in which the bounty hunter
walks down a hallway with vader lando
and lobot so john morton got to be boba
fett for that one scene that isn't
morton's only role in empire either he
also played rebel pilot dark ralter luke
skywalker's gunner during the battle of
huff having previously worked as a
stuntman morton didn't do much more
acting after his career although he did
score smaller roles in two other sci-fi
classics released the same year as
empire flash gordon and superman 2.
while jeremy bullock and john morton
played the physical role of boba fett in
the original star wars trilogy the voice
fans initially heard coming out of
fett's helmet was that of jason wingreen
what if he doesn't survive he's worth a
lot to me
this isn't the case for many modern star
wars fans however as the 2004 dvd
releases swapped to win green's voice
with tim wearer morrisons what if he
doesn't survive he's worth a lot to me
when green claimed that for him
portraying boba fett took no more than
10 minutes of work there's an argument
to be made that win green wasn't treated
very fairly by the star wars franchise
after lending his voice to the famous
bounty hunter his name wasn't included
and the credits of empire strikes back
and his involvement wasn't even public
knowledge until around the year 2000
most shockingly he never received any
residual compensation for his work even
though his voice was used for boba fett
action figures when green died on
christmas day 2015 he was 95 years old
back in 1981 george lucas sold the radio
rights for the original star wars
trilogy to npr for the whopping sum of
one dollar the filmmaker had been
listening to nbr since his college days
and was inclined to feel generous
towards them all three movies were
eventually adapted into radio dramas
split into half hour long installments
certain actors from the movies reprised
their roles but most of the other
characters had to be recast including
boba fett in the 1983 empire strikes
back radio play boba fett was played by
alan rosenberg an actor who has worked
steadily since the late 1970s mostly in
television unfortunately by the time a
return of the jedi adaptation could be
made federal funding cuts and a number
of other factors had put the radio play
on hold it wasn't until 1996 that the
six-part drama was recorded with ed
bagley jr taking over the role of boba
fett around the same time in 1994 the
popular dark empire comic book series
was adapted into two audio dramas for
the role of boba fett character actor
joseph hacker was chosen packer has
appeared on dozens of tv shows over the
years from quantum leap to 24. the final
actor to play phet in an audio drama was
the otherwise unknown tim glovatsky who
played the bounty hunter in dark forces
rebel agent an adaptation of the novel
of the same name
when the special edition of a new hope
hit theaters in 1997 it included an
uncompleted scene from the original
production in which jabba the hurt and
han solo talk before the falcon leaves
tatooine along with a group of armed
henchmen jabba is accompanied by the
silent but intimidating figure of boba
fett the bounty hunter was worked into
the story digitally courtesy of
industrial light and magic animator mark
austin who dons the iconic armor for the
scene while his appearance is brief in a
new hope austin obviously feels attached
to the role he even played the bounty
hunter for a second time on the boba
fett fan club's web series no
disintegrations these episodes are meant
to be transmissions from boba fett's
ship most of which take place within
specific chapters of the saga
when it came time to produce a special
edition of return of the jedi george
lucas apparently wanted more boba fett
even though he never did manage to work
in an escape from the sarlacc pit what
fans do get however is more time with
the armored bounty hunter dronie
extended song and dance number in jabba
the hutt's palace for most of these new
boba fett shots special effects artists
don bees stepped into the character's
iconic armor nelson hall another vfx
artist provided the rest of the footage
for fete in a 2016 interview with
starwars.com bees revealed he also
played a musician in jabba's band as
well as a whole bunch of stormtroopers
and imperial officers in a new hope
apparently he and nelson hall stuck
themselves in so many scenes that their
effects supervisor actually had to ask
them to tone it down
if you're a fan of animated star wars
properties you've likely heard tom
kane's voice he's a narrator of star
wars the clone wars as well as the voice
of yoda in that series and a number of
other productions as far as boba fett is
concerned however kane has portrayed the
bounty hunter three times albeit only in
star wars video games kane's first
outing as boba fett came during 2000
star wars demolition a game in which
players put different vehicles from the
franchise against each other kane voice
fed once again in a 2001 real-time
strategy game star wars galactic
battlegrounds finally he played fett in
2003's star wars jedi knight jedi
academy which has a particularly special
place in many fans hearts
boba fett this doesn't concern you jedi
just walk away
attack of the clones reveals a whole lot
about boba fett first it's shown that
the bounty hunter is a clone created as
payment to jango fett by the clone
makers of camino in exchange for the use
of his dna to create their clone army
the movie also makes clear that boba
fett's appreciation of violence emerged
at a young age finally it's revealed
that fett saw his father die on geonosis
and mace windu's hands the image of
young boba fett holding django's helmet
is one of the most memorable of the
prequel trilogy younger boba fett is
played by the new zealand-born actor
daniel logan playing boba fett left an
interesting mark on the young performer
too when looper spoke to him in april
2020 he revealed that like jake lloyd he
suffered plenty of bullying for his role
in the trilogy he said i think we're
very very blessed that we came in during
the era right before social media and
this whole entire internet explosion
because i think it could have turned out
worse luckily this hasn't stopped him
embracing his connection with the star
wars saga and when logan got the call to
a prizes role in the clone wars he
pretty much jumped at the opportunity
in 1998 lucasarts and nintendo teamed up
to release the flight action game star
wars rogue squadron in this game the
player guides the eponymous rebel group
through a variety of mission objectives
it proved popular enough to spawn two
sequels including 2003's star wars rogue
squadron 3 rebel strike actor chris cox
played multiple characters in rebel
strike including boba fett his fed
performance are spotlighted by a mission
that recreates leia's futile pursuit of
the bounty hunter when he leaves best
bin with the frozen han solo while rebel
strike is the only game in which cox
portrayed boba fett is only one of many
star wars games he's worked on the
prolific voice actor can be heard across
the star wars galaxy from fallen order
to battlefront to the force unleashed
well fans in his home country of new
zealand were already familiar with his
work before he stepped into the star
wars universe it was timera morrison's
pitch perfect performance as jango fett
an attack of the clones that made him
known to audiences around the world
since that film establishes that boba is
a clone of django it also laid the
foundation for morrison to soften the
disappointment so many fans suffered in
return of the jedi by finally returning
boba fett to the land of the living
blues happening
morrison voiced boba fett a number of
times before he played him in a
live-action capacity though when the
special editions of the original trilogy
got new home releases in 2004 jason
wingreen's voice was replaced with
morrisons morrison went on to voice the
character in a number of video games
including 2005's battlefront 2 and
2006's empire at war more recently in
the second season of the mandalorian
morrison's boba fett joins up with din
jaren to help rescue grogu from the
clutches of moff gideon try saying that
six times that season ended with the
revelation that phet will be getting his
own solo series on disney plus in
december 2021
d bradley baker has enjoyed a long
varied and incredibly successful voice
acting career including a whole lot of
work in the star wars universe he's
perhaps best known for voicing captain
rex and the clone wars rebels and the
bad batch though he also played a number
of clone troopers in each series baker
portrayed boba fett in both of the force
unleashed games too in 2011 the year
after force unleash 2 was released fans
were able to hear him voice a bounty
hunter once again albeit as part of a
very different production that year
disney's hollywood studios debuted star
tours the adventures continue an
attraction that sees baker reprises role
as the galaxy's most dangerous bounty
hunter
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the second season of the mandalorian
where morrison's boba fett joins up with
dinjarin to help rescue grogu from the
clutches of moff gideon seriously guys
come on subscribe to our youtube channel
and to the bell so you don't miss a
single one